right i think we'll make a start now uh
welcome back everyone really nice to see
you all again
and uh this is the the fourth and the
final webinar
in the series of the iedq workshop on
indigenous people's food systems
biocultural heritage and the sustainable
development goals
great so this final webinar is focusing
on exploring research methods
interdisciplinary methods and
decolonizing methods
for research on indigenous peoples food
systems
so we've had a very rich discussion in
the last three webinars
we've heard from many indigenous experts
and i would like to start by
highlighting some of the key points that
have been made
particularly relating to the priorities
for research
so we've heard that indigenous people's
food systems and biocultural heritage
are fundamental for indigenous people's
food sovereignty
identity spirituality health and
well-being
and for everyday life and that's um
we heard that they also play a
significant role
in the transition to sustainable food
systems and can make
important contributions to economic
uh national economies as we heard
yesterday from hindu ibrahim
a pastoralist from chad i think
a key message i've got also is that
there's a really
strong urgency um but indigenous food
systems
face many threats traditional knowledge
is disappearing very fast
and research must focus on these threats
and challenges and not only on the
indigenous food systems themselves
the threats include restrictions on
forest use
and resource use spread of of modern
agriculture
and modernization of cultures and
inappropriate
economic development and also education
western education systems
the second message that i got from
yesterday
is the critical need to do more research
on indigenous people's land rights
as hindu ibrahim explained most land
belongs to governments
and land that is vital for pastoralists
is being sold off to sedentary people
and that
is a massive threat to their indigenous
food system
we heard um also from the
uh representative from the arctic region
of russia
that the introduction of industrial
development has almost destroyed
their traditional way of life and that
traditional
food culture of hunting and fishing is
very close to nature
and that that diet is actually essential
for survival in that harsh climate
and that in response to the challenges
of climate change
and they must return to their indigenous
food system
and for this they need to preserve the
land
and we learnt that for hunter-gatherers
in tropical rainforests who
are mobile egalitarian very culturally
diverse
they are also facing many threats from
economic expansion and from protected
areas
so we also heard from um from the
academic side
that land rights is an issue which is
under-researched
we heard from hindu ibrahim that
indigenous peoples don't call it food
security they call it
food sovereignty and this is a priority
for research as well as food sovereignty
is essential to sustain indigenous
knowledge systems
and also she emphasized that maintaining
seven generations thinking is really
important
not only in chad but we also heard that
indigenous peoples in china have this
seven generation thinking hindu also
stressed the need to get
traditional knowledge respected on the
same level as science
and we heard from fao that um
traditional knowledge contains ancestral
wisdom
whereas often science is just
information
frang roy uh stressed the need to gather
evidence
of how destructive industrial
agriculture
is on indigenous peoples for example in
asia
and he also stressed the need for
researchers to respect the value
of indigenous knowledge rather than
viewing it
as backward as this sometimes happens
and the need to mainstream indigenous
perspectives
in research and to respect indigenous
people's rights
and the rights enshrined in the un
declaration on the rights of indigenous
peoples
and to support indigenous methods of
knowledge transmission like storytelling
and he stressed the need for a
multicultural research approach that
blends indigenous knowledge and science
and we heard that the multi multiple
evidence-based approach
is one method to do this we heard that
indigenous peoples would like
academics to recognize them as equally
expert
and the academics can play a useful role
in helping to show that indigenous
peoples are experts
and that they should support research
that is led
by indigenous peoples conventional
research that is externally led is not
useful
to indigenous peoples and can never
fully understand them
is something that hindu ibrahim
emphasized
but there's also we also heard that
there's much scope for collaboration
when there is
mutual respect
and um
we heard on the interdisciplinary issue
that
indigenous peoples don't have separate
fields of study everything is
interlinked
so community-led research can provide a
framework for interdisciplinary research
and we heard that it is crucial to
empower indigenous communities
and to support community networking and
to
also understand the governance issues
and engage at policy level
and that more research is needed on
gender and women's health issues
and finally we heard from fao about the
new global hub on indigenous
people's food systems that brings
together universities
un agencies and indigenous peoples and
seeks to inform
policy processes like the the world food
system summit in
in 2021 and um
uh just to mention that um john uh
fernandez de linoa uh from fao
replied to my question after the webinar
because there wasn't enough time
but um he confirmed that uk universities
can become members of the hub
and that the emphasis is placed on
institutions and research centers that
are doing hands-on research with
indigenous peoples
and they're respecting the principle of
free prior and informed consent
so for this webinar we will explore
indigenous
and decolonizing research methods and
we'll also explore
interdisciplinary research methods so
the first session
will focus on interdisciplinary methods
methods that draw on more than one
discipline
to better understand and protect
indigenous people's food systems
and to enhance the evidence of their
importance and to help
address the challenges they face and
then
after a 15-minute break we'll look at
the um
we're having a panel um of indigenous
peoples
talking about decolonizing and
indigenous research methods
that seek to empower indigenous peoples
and help to address the key challenges
they face
through the research process so they
strengthen culture
indigenous knowledge and help to
strengthen rights to land
and to to strengthen biodiversity etc
so i will hand over to philippa now
she's going to chair the first session
um just to briefly remind presenters
that we are a very diverse audience so
please don't use
um academic jargon and also
for the q a that follows um each session
today we would
prefer if everybody can raise their hand
or use the raised hand
function and briefly introduce
themselves rather than
using the chat but you can use the chat
if we run out of time
okay thank you so much i'll hand over to
philippa
morning everyone um so yeah this first
panel
on is on interdisciplinary methods for
research on
indigenous and traditional crops whole
food systems
and temporal changes and i'm going to
start by talking about combining
ethnobotanical and
historical approaches so ethnobotanical
approaches to studying
indigenous food systems can include
documenting crop diversity and uses
the relationships between crops and land
use and between crops and foods
all these elements are connected and
subject to dynamic change
there are multitudes of reasons for
growing crop varieties as we all know
including for different uses such as
food or fodder for their taste and
cooking properties
for their resilient traits or yield and
for their suitability
to specific moments within seasonal
cycles
or specific patches of land
for documenting crop diversity and uses
within the
local ecological context could include
recording
which crops are grown in different micro
environments and patches
created for example by differences in
soils or altitude
or through land use systems and
management such as terracing
and home gardens and studying crops from
cultivations through to cooking
practices
can include all the practical steps from
harvesting
food to storage and food preparation
and how they connect with material
culture technologies
cultural practices and knowledge so many
crops
considered minor today have been more
important in the past
and documenting farmers memories can
provide valuable information
about crop pieces about the advantages
of different crops
about growing methods that are useful in
being forgotten
and reasons for any of these changes
historical documents and
archaeobotanical data can then provide
further information
on the long-term crop histories and less
insights into their local environmental
suitability
over the past years i've been
collaborating with sudanese colleagues
in nubian communities studying
traditional crops
the project is based in the hyper arid
north where agriculture is centered on
family farms
and dependent on the river nile so i've
got a couple of slides to show now
um that introduced my collaborators and
some of the farming environments
and associated traditional material
culture so
i will just so we interviewed farmers
about crops they have grown today
and in the past to compare and their
uses and where they are grown
we recorded cultivation and crop
processing methods
focusing on cereals and pulses as well
as
associated foods elderly farmers were
also asked how practices have changed
with the introduction of new crops and
methods
especially since the mid-20th century
when traditional
irrigation systems changed so several
previously stapled crops
are now minor food crops and there are
many reasons for such
changes including shifts in food
preferences
and processing methods and many of these
crops are now just grown for
home use in small patches especially
along the river banks
tutorial beans are a dominant commercial
and food pulse crop
but previously a wide diversity of
pulses were eaten more frequently
especially lablab and cowpea and baked
wheat bread has also become an
increasingly dominant food partly
replacing flatbreads
which also used to be made with a wider
range
of cereal and pulse so changes in crops
and foods are also reflected by material
shifts
such as the disappearance of many
traditional kitchens
and storage rooms and the dominant
hybrid crops in use today can only be
grown in the winter
and then dependent on intensive
irrigation in contrast the local
cultivators of
african crops that were dominant in the
past
are low input and could be grown
throughout the year
and these previously important crop
species have a long history of use in
the archaeological record of the region
helping highlight their long-term
stories
and environmental suitability
the connecting botanical plant
identifications and local names
is always a key element of
ethno-botanical research
and recording the names of crops and
types of foods in nubian
as well as in arabic was also important
some words were more specific in libyans
and this knowledge is also endangered as
it is mostly held within the memories of
the older generations
and nubian languages are themselves also
endangered
so to help preserve the local
agricultural histories the findings were
summarized in a booklet that was shared
with local communities and its content
and design
involved the local community and
teachers throughout
i will now present a video from my
colleague mohamed saad
who discusses our research in sudan
further
mohammed works at the national museum in
khartoum
agriculture in the past depends on the
symbol system of irrigation
shadow as and sagia as well as
traditional tools to cultivate and
harvest the crops
it is very important to talk to the old
people
and all farmers about their
agriculture because some of them is
still they grow the all
all the crops for foods in a small area
because they are important as easy to
grow when it is
hot and the main crops is
wheat and beans and deaths
also the all farmers they have good
knowledge
especially about growing ropes season
snail float
some change happened
when the farmers use the modern
system of irrigation and
also they use a machine to cultivate
their crops
some farmers they change from food crops
to
cash crops as well as
also the some change happen because
people they grow like a big land instead
of a small
land brilliant thanks and now we're
going to move on quickly to
raj puri from the university of kent
who's going to
talk about using ethnobotany and
participatory action research to
document
agrobiodiversity over to you
okay uh hello everyone uh pleasure to be
here
um nice to see you all um
okay i'm gonna try and link these three
things um as best that i can
i don't have any slides but i'm happy to
answer questions afterwards okay
ethnobotany
then studies the relationship of people
to plants
and we think of that relationship as
mutual
an interdependency caused by
co-evolutionary
processes that results in what we like
to call biocultural diversity
i'm sure many of you are familiar with
this so our food plants
and other cultivated crops are some of
the clearest examples
of this ongoing co-evolutionary process
wherein we have
manipulated and domesticated these
plants and produced
this agrobiodiversity but they have also
domesticated us
and produced the knowledge that we need
to grow protect
harvest uh store and use
those plants and those uses derive
ultimately
from the materials symbolic and
spiritual needs
beliefs practices and values that
underpin the cultural lives
of peoples around the world so when we
speak of agrobiodiversity
that's only half the story for what are
plant varieties
seeds and other plant parts without the
cultural context
and shared knowledges that enliven them
and give them meaning
so losing one aspect here necessarily
leads to losses in the other
maintaining crop diversity requires
maintaining the recipes for dishes
the celebratory feasts and rituals that
require these special varieties
conserving biocultural diversity
therefore is a multi-disciplinary task
requiring integrated research on this
co-evolutionary relationship
on this biocultural diversity on its
resilience
and threats to it from globalization and
climate change to name just a couple
and on its changing nature culture as it
transforms
in the face of both internal and
external forces
and trends of change so there are many
manuals out there
and many examples of research of this
kind being conducted around the world
i wanted today to focus on participatory
action research or par
using tested and tried ethnobotanical
methods to solve
problems and but being conducted by
residents of communities
who are trying to resolve these problems
and develop new directions for their
lives and livelihoods
so our role in this is as consultants
uh and trainers gathering together
people to help them think through
issues providing training and perhaps
funds to collect and analyze data for
themselves
about themselves uh helping them to
protect store and disseminate their
knowledge
as they see fit now one fact that we've
learned
is that no one knows everything about
the plants
people know and use and what people do
know often differs
there are knowledges of men of women
of children of elders of farmers of
gatherers of hunters
of fishers so one important role of an
ethnobotanist
in par is to find ways to get people to
share their own knowledge with each
other
you can think of great examples mark
plotkins sorcerer's apprentice in the
1980s and 90s
trying to get children to learn the
traditional medicine of their elders
in sabah we had a project studying
rattan and basketry
and the the elders of the community set
up workshops to teach their children
because they realized that they didn't
know
about basketry about rattan about the
plants and dyes that went into it
so we do this through interviewing for
instance in focus groups
of say only older women or only younger
men
so they can learn from each other in the
process of doing this research
and we do this through community mapping
exercises
through inventorying gardens or
interviewing along plant trails all of
these can be done by community members
so they may collect specimens and seeds
for a community herbarium
a garden or a seed bank or
sit down and write a plant manual in
local language for their kids
or they may choose to record it all on
video using what we call participatory
video
or pv developed by our friends at
insight share
i've been associated with several of
these projects over the years
and our students at kent have been sort
of leading the way with
their project's engagements with
communities to produce gardens manuals
and videos
around the world i'd also like to point
up the work done by the global diversity
foundation
uh who emphasized long-term commitments
to communities
to foster
[Music]
foster capacity building so that
communities can document their own
knowledges
in india where i've been working
recently a tree researchers have helped
communities deal with the impacts of
invasive species
on forest undergrowth by setting up
nurseries to grow some of their
important wild food and medicinal plants
in their own home gardens
in sabah gdf led a par project with
dusun communities
and ngos to use participatory resource
inventory methods
to document knowledge and use of plants
for the purposes of designing
community use zones in the crocker
state park all that research
uh and training and their gis maps that
they made themselves
became essential and vital when a
proposal to dam and flood their valley
was dramatically announced fortunately
they were successful in killing off this
this idea
so there are other examples i can talk
about and i'm interested to hear
from the other panel members what they
think
but that's all i have to say and thanks
very much for listening
thank you very much it was brilliant
um we're going to pass over quickly now
to roger blench who's going to
talk about using ethnobotanic
ethnobotany botanical linguistics
and anthropology to understand
indigenous
food systems okay i was ticked off for
not having pictures
in this slideshow so you'll just have to
put up with text sorry about that
okay um i'm not also going to talk about
the advertised topic
since but rather the whole issue of
documentation which is
a personal obsession
as far as i'm concerned the
documentation of basic ethnobiological
systems
remains in a very poor state and
in my view has in fact deteriorated in
the last 40 years
i mean a lot of discussion at this
workshop is about activism
and of course that is absolutely crucial
but
to my way of thinking activism has to
have an evidential base in other words
you know it's easy to say we must
protect xxxx but
exactly what are we protecting that
that's important to understand
there's also a problem of the making
useful
older documentation there's a load of
older documentation
often in obscure sources or in
problematic languages
these are not easily available
to present researchers present activists
so turning older stuff into useful
material also seems to me an important
priority
and making it accessible and and
something i i mentioned the other day
i've been working on which is turning
uh ethno-botanical stuff into android
applications that people can use on
their phones
i also mentioned an important uh thing
which seems to me
people put out ethnobotanical databases
on the internet
this is mainly because they get grants
and they have data and they put it up
and it's useful it's then
of course unmaintained because the grant
finishes and the creator of the project
moves on
um this goes back i think to what fao
was talking about we have to to scrape
if you like
all this documentation which people have
worked hard to prepare
and put it in a form that's accessible
and interlinked with other sources so so
there's a lot of stuff
to be done on making
data available in common formats which
can be consulted
by ngos by activists by scientists so
so it has a sort of multi-use format
interdisciplinary research well we've
heard a great deal about that and this
what this section is about um
my experience of certain organizations
even those represented this workshop
is that they speak in fork tongues in
other words you can certainly have a
unit that's interested in
local information and local cultural
practices
and useful plants but at the same time
there are other units in the same body
which are interested in promoting hard
science and
publishing papers in nature and science
and so on
for whom all this cultural stuff is a
load of hui frankly
and of course that's unfortunately where
the money is these days
and and we see this in lots of lots of
disciplines not only uh
archaeology as well as ethnobotany
there's a problem with funders funders
like to support advances in individual
disciplines
and this makes plant scientists in
particular turn away from economic
botany
um i've talked to many botanists for
whom this is all
just you know fluff if you like people
publish enormous
uh hardcore botanical surveys of
individual countries we're not a single
mention
of even whether plants are domestic or
non-domestic let alone anything to do
with uses and local names
similarly there's a major problem i
think
with the way information is reviewed in
journals in other words you know if you
do botanical documentation of a
particular group of people
actually publishing it in a in a journal
is really quite hard i mean you can put
it out there on the web and i think
that's what a lot of people do
but i think this there are great
difficulties
in even getting out basic documentation
i'll give you an example here i work in
nigeria and i work in northeast india
in those two places 502 and to
around 250 languages are spoken
i should say in nigeria there may be
satisfactory ethnobotanical and ethno
zoological documentation for maybe four
languages and none not one
in northeast india and i don't mean you
know a
list of a couple of plants but i mean a
proper
solid documentation such as been
undertaken in central america so
there's a real uphill task
a crucial thing in my view is a lack of
field guides
field guides are essential essential
to doing serious ethnoscience
ethnobiology
if you can't even discuss you can't even
discuss the identification of
plants and animals with people because
you don't have
field guide so even if you are willing
for example you you can't easily get
uh you know a chance at identification
uh so i just want to want to emphasize
really
this absence of field guides and
maybe an absence of a data bank
of non-copyright photographs which can
be used to compile field guides
so i think all these are issues we have
to think about
okay brilliant thank you very much so
we're just going to start quickly
for um some questions
which just reset my clock
um how are we doing 35 so
yeah if we could just stop for around
five minutes of questions that would
be great um has anyone got any questions
they can
raise their hand um or or put a question
into the chat box and then afterwards
we'll move on to the next
round of flash talks
um sorry to have a question from me but
just
um as nobody raised their hand
immediately
um thank you very much all of you that
was really interesting
um i wanted to ask a question to roger
um i've worked quite a bit on
protecting traditional knowledge and
the main route by which um
biopiracy happens in
unauthorized use and commercial use of
traditional knowledge
is through published databases of
so i was just wondering how you address
that issue
because obviously this documentation
work is important
and as you say it's really important to
have the evidence base to support
activism
but um the concern is by making it
available that anybody could get their
hands on it and abuse
you know use it inappropriately and
without benefits for communities
so i'm just wondering how you address
that issue thanks
well obviously the first important thing
is that you
must get consent for dissemination of
knowledge from the people
you're working with um i have to say
i've never found this a problem
in the two areas of the world i work
people love
the idea that you know their culture is
being disseminated more widely in the
world
but these issues certainly have come up
in the amazon
although i do understand it's become
less of a problem in more in more recent
times because
more companies are less interested in
uh biodiversity chemicals and more
interested in in sort of mechanical
processes for developing things but
it remains an issue and i think the only
way around this
is to ensure that you definitely have
the consent
of the community for the dissemination
of knowledge and then
what can you do if it's out there it's
out there um
nobody can predict what might might be
found to be useful
um so there's no two way there's no real
way around this as far as i can see
uh it's consent is crucial
okay there's a question here um
from george mcallister um
about could the speakers share their
thoughts on how to undertake
participatory action research in a time
of covet
um perhaps in terms of ethics tools and
practices
for building trust and capacity for
community-led processes
raj i think this might be for you
yeah thanks good question very difficult
uh in fact we just submitted a grant to
the esrc here in the uk
to try and get funding to do just that
when it was uh
shot down as being uh one of the
comments one of their viewers said that
uh they wondered if it was unethical to
interview the same family three times in
a year
so that just goes to show you perhaps
who's reviewing these
these proposals but our our goal there
was to
uh work in pre-existing with
pre-existing relationships we have with
a couple of communities in london and
birmingham
uh already so making use of pre-existing
networks
and getting members of the the
communities that we were interested in
afro-jamaican
for caribbean communities and south
asian communities
to do research amongst their own people
amongst their own neighbors and families
to kind of get a sense of how they were
reacting to coven 19 in terms of their
use of
traditional healing methods self-care
etc
and so you know the way to do it really
is
again through good uh and close rapport
building and close relationships with
pre-existing
um uh networks in the case of covet 19.
starting something brand new might be a
bit difficult
we note i was also part of an online
survey
and we noted that very few members of
the south asian or the afro-caribbean
community were answering online surveys
about what they were doing during covet
19.
and it was clear that that's why
ethnographic research
as much as you could do in terms of
face-to-face interviewing whether it's
by
zoom or telephone or whatsapp or
on the doorstep was really important
you know people from minority groups
often
are just either don't have linguistic
or or digital capabilities for talents
for using those kinds of online surveys
i don't know i hope i hope that answered
some of your questions yeah thank you
thank you thank you if i can contact you
outside of this
forum that would be wonderful thanks oh
yeah pleasure pleasure
there's a few comments here in the in
the chat
um
i'm just reading harriet's
okay so that that might be something
that someone else could
is anyone could answer answer that
question but i think we also need to
to move on um with the
christine what's what's the best way to
carry
on answering some of the questions here
if we need to get going with the
the talks would it be good for people to
just send a couple of replies into the
chat
yes i think that would be the best um
while we move on if you
if you could reply to the question in
the chat i think
cool well anyway we better move on um
so then next um kind of talks
still talking about more different sort
of into multi-disciplinary methods
um and so we're going to start now with
paul wilkin from q um who's
going to present on botanical science
for conserving
orphan crops and indigenous knowledge
over to you paul
well if that isn't a big enough task for
three minutes i also thought i would say
that
the comments i'm about to make also
cover niche crops and wild
wild exploited plant resources really
across the whole spectrum
of domestication i think what we're
talking about
in terms of botanical science boils down
to four key questions
we've already started to touch on some
of those the first one is
what is it inventory is is a critical
part so
species uh land raises funds varieties
but also looking at
particular trait variation uh and in
current
uh research approaches we've also want
to look at genetics and genomics as ways
of describing and understanding
the diversity that we're seeing in front
of us and we want to see
participatory shared and restored
knowledge within that context
the next key question is where is it we
want to geolocate the material we're
looking
at and that brings into play a whole
load of spatial research methods
that i'm not going to talk about today
time
and then once we've done those
preliminary steps and those are the two
most critical first steps
then we start to think about
conservation uh
conservation is vital we are all aware
of that and the
population of the globe is increasingly
aware of that
so first we would look at in situ
methods of conservation
we'd look at cultivation either in situ
or close to in situ
and then once those methods are exhorted
we'd move to the ex-situ methods
in particular around seed banking or
cryo preservation
and all of those are the suite of
approaches that are open to us to make
sure that we have access to the relevant
germplasm
uh and then the bit which is often
forgotten the part on the end
uh is what do we do with the conserved
material how do we regenerate plants
from that and how do we get them back
where they're needed
so we would be wanting to look at things
like seed germination ecology
uh and the extraction of
preserved material and regeneration of
it as the as critical approaches to
delivering the plant resources that
people need
i think i will leave it at that
thank you paul um i was wondering as
well if you could just say
something really briefly on um maybe how
there's different approaches for
different categories of crops so
for example the the seed crops like
cereals versus the
vegetative vegetative crops
um from the national perspective
for many of the steps one to three
really to be in situ
for the in-situ work or or
characterizing it
evidently uh seed-bearing crops like
cereals are relatively easy
to bank crops which are
based on underground organs which are
vegetatively propagated
are much harder to conserve they usually
require geoplasm collections which are
expensive to maintain and often
uh find it very difficult to retain
information associated with the
accessions in those collections
so they're often two or three years down
the line are often quite worthless
and then you end up resorting to cryo
approaches which are extremely expensive
uh and technical and difficult to
approach but that may be the vital way
of preserving so
iota in nigeria uh concerns much of its
yam diversity through cryo because it's
the only approach that works
okay thanks and now we're going to
briefly explain what cryo is
there's a lot of technical jargon coming
through thank you yeah
i forgot tissue culture which is another
way to conserve material
cryopreservation so freezing of of
embryos
down at very low temperatures and then
they can then be re plants can be
regrown
from those preserved embryos thank you
um and now we're going to move on to
um where am i
to typiana union from q who's going to
talk about using plant diversity and
ethnobotany to support
community livelihoods thank you yes
thank you philippe i'm going to share my
screen i have a slide
yeah okay well good morning everybody
um so um i'm going here
to talk about our research method
through
the project the youtube project that
i've been coordinating for several years
and this is a project um that was
developed
and carry out in africa and also latin
america
so um we the aim of this project
was to um basically conserve xc2
indigenous useful plants those one that
were important for local community by
building actually the local capacity
to successfully conserve and
use them so the main components
of the project can be summarized as you
follow so we have one part of targeting
and prioritizing the species
so by using different methods so one
hand we did
of course literature review to see what
was already available there
on the other hand we are being really
carrying out electron botanica surveys
um by working directly with the local
community
uh but uh at the end we had really to
come up
with a short list of most important
species where we can we could focus um
and on and do really our
conservation and sustainable use
activity and we did this through
a workshop participatory workshop
and then another component as being on
the seed conservation
social conservation um was applied to
the priority species and we did the same
conservation together with local
community and with
our collaborators in country by
collecting and
storing the seeds then we have been
propagating those seeds in order to
have them available and
not only for research but of course for
the community
in a way in this way we establish
community garden but also
forestry plots in the case of of kenya
where we've been propagating
this priority and cultivating the
species and lastly um
we have been developing methods um
and in order to create some income in
the community
uh through the um selling of uh
plants directly sealing but also a plant
product
in particularly food products food
products so how did we do all of this
well we apply a participatory approach
as i said by working together with the
community
from the beginning to the end and and
also
reaching out to other stakeholders by
involving um
them in our activities and in our
products
our approach uh was also
multi-disciplinary
as we carry out different kind of
research we carry out a thrombotomical
research
but also we carry out research on c
biology and ecology
to inform both the management of the
seeds but also the conservation of the
seeds
and how to propagate those seeds and
then we develop
propagation protocol and we have also
established
some um agricultural plots in order to
look at the growth rate and the survival
of these species
and so to conclude um what did we do
with all this information
well the one that also we generated we
give we give it back to the local
community
through training but also we help
enhancing the local facilities and and
also we summarize all our um
all our information in the in a book
that you can see
on here on um on the corner on the right
and we produce this book so um which is
a while plan for a sustainable future
we compile all the information that we
collected from the community
our own information that we generated
through the research and try to condense
it in this
in this book where we have uh in their
eternal botanical information where
other sort of botanical information
species description
so that people can identify the species
and that's something that came out
earlier in the talk
but at the same time how to know how to
deal with species from a conservation
and sustainable
um user point of view so
this is a book that is aimed to
practitioners and in country and um but
also
um that they work in development outside
uh with aim really to help them use the
species
and conserve them and in a way that can
help addressing
uh community livelihoods and
conservation at the same time
thank you very much thank you so much
um so we're gonna move on to
um and julie and gary
vasquez who's going to talk about
identifying archaeo botanical evidence
for plant processing techniques
um yeah over to you so
basically i am a phd student at
university college london and i do
arcu botanical analyses to understand
human plant dynamics
in of indigenous communities in the
caribbean
through archaeological methods and one
of the things that i realized is that
through our cubotany um you know we can
identify
many types of plants from the
archaeological record however
um at times we don't understand how to
process them
because as as has been said in the
in the workshop that there's um
indigenous knowledge that gets lost
however i am here to kind of like
control repose
and the reality is that it's not lost
our ancestors have this information
um in the in the archaeological records
you know they are the bearers the
custodians of this information that got
lost and we can work using our key
botanical methods to
bring it back to the present and this
image is just um
one of the activities that i do to
understand
the how the different methods of
processing
manioc which is here um
and this also helps not just you know
going through the motions of actually
cooking
the dish which is cassava bread
um which you can see here but also it
helps you understand how those things
get to the archaeological record
and the way that i do this type of
revitalization of indigenous food
practices is by
using collection of carbonized plant
remains
and then from those there are fragments
which look like food
or are especially also
tuber fragments and using
scanning electro microscope you can
potentially identify those
foods but beyond the simple
identification of species or
what type of food it is you can actually
try to assess
um food taste preferences
and actually if this type of research is
done on a more larger scale
you can try and start getting a sense of
contextualizing the food habits of
people
um and that's something that i'm trying
to work on throughout my
work and not just as i said before
revitalizing
indigenous food practices which is this
image
which is from the taino new year
celebration
in my island of boriken
thank you so much for that and really
really great through
love um seeing all those images as well
we're all getting hungry already
um and now we will talk about
long-term um crop history of the
archaeobotany of crop history
so passing over to dorian fuller from
ucl
okay good so i'm i'm an archaeobotomist
like uh julian who just heard from
archaeobotany is the study of the
preserved plants from ancient human
sites so it's the archaeology of
plants instead of the archaeology of
pottery or some other kind of artifact
and it can inform us about the
history of crop repertoires within a
region so which crops have come into use
and out of use over the long term
it can tell us about ancient changes and
diversification and crops
it often tells us about within a
particular region how
much of an impact the post-columbian
exchange has been
between crops from the new world and old
world
being shifted around and we heard
you know you will find maize in parts of
asia and africa being very important
and that's of course a change that's
happened within recent centuries
uh it can also tell us about lost crops
or what we might call orphaned crops or
crops that are disappearing and that's
kind of what i wanted to focus on today
with a few examples
and i've listed some there in red and
i'm going to quickly
walk you through walk you through kind
of three
uh stories about lost or disappearing
crops
that archaeology can tell us about that
you might not
otherwise expect to learn very much
about
so it's something that can in a sense
complement the kind of ethno-botanical
documentation
that we've been talking about
so the first of those that i'd like to
talk about is brown top millet
or brachiaria ramosa and this is really
the lost staple grain of south india of
the deccan
region uh now it's not completely lost
there is a region
in northwestern tamil nadu and adjacent
karnataka
where it is grown on a very small scale
or at least it was still grown in the
1990s on a very small scale the last
documented reference to this i know of
is from a paper published in economic
botany in the year 2000
by a japanese scholar and some indian
colleagues and they documented i think
two villages that grew this crop that
in the late 1990s and i have a picture
there
of a map that shows the region where
that modern cultivation was
and some of the dishes and breads that
were made out of this millet
most of which were kind of ritual food
so it was maintained mainly for
particular festivals but the area
highlighted in blue
broadly speaking is and all those dots
are where we have
archaeological evidence for this as a
grain
and often as the dominant grain the
staple grain on many of those sites
so for from around four and a half
thousand years ago up until
maybe 1500 years ago this was in many
regions a staple food so it is very much
declined as a millet and that's a story
that we can only learn about
through the archaeological evidence
which then tells us that it was
suitable in much more of much more
widespread importance and what remains
in recent times is just a you know a
small sample of its past
diversity and cultural use
another example of crops that are
completely lost to us
in the ethnographic present are some of
the examples of north american
domesticates
uh and there are very two very well
documented examples are a lost can a
podium so this is a
pseudo cereal similar to modern quinoa
but a separate north american species
and ice also iva annual oil seed and
i've got pictures there of iva annual
seeds it's
distantly related to sunflower
archaeological evidence
shows that it undergoes domestication so
you get a larger seeded variety
so-called macrocarpa variety now this
variety does not exist
today there's no living biological
versions of it it only exists in the
archaeological record
but it's a fairly major crop and oil
seeded crop that's cultivated
in this mississippi basin from about
from more than 4 000 years ago up until
at least a thousand years ago
probably later we don't really know when
it goes extinct as a crop
and i would guess that it's around the
time of european contact when you have
such a large
a decimation of native populations due
to european diseases
so again it's something that has
potential but
it's lost to our kind of ethnographic
documentation
and then the third case i'd like to give
is one that would seem like a crop we
know a lot about
wheat but in fact there's a lot of kinds
of wheat that we don't really know very
much about
today one thing to note is that wheat
comes in lots of different genetic types
as several species of wheat really
today most of the wheat we eat and most
of what's cultivated
is either bread wheat or durum wheat
durum wheat is u is cultivated
especially in the mediterranean to make
pasta
and couscous but these are really quite
recent phenomena
these two species of wheat that dominate
so they start to really become important
in the roman period about two thousand
years ago
and in places like britain maybe only a
thousand years ago
and prior to that there's a real
diversity of wheat species and i've kind
of circled them there with different
colors
durian i'll have to just wrap up quickly
30 seconds more and what the one point i
would say is that there's two
varieties here which i've highlighted in
uh
two grade nine corner there's a there's
a green arrow pointing to it
and there's triticum timofevy there's a
purple arrow pointing to it
which are really dominant species in the
neolithic and bronze age and have
basically gone extinct
since then so we can see that um
the wheat diversity around us today and
used traditionally
is not necessarily doesn't necessarily
reflect the long term so archaeology can
reveal these patterns of long-term
change and that's what i want to say
brilliant thank you um cool so
now we've going to um present a video
from matthew davis at ucl who
will be talking about documenting
traditional crops agri systems and
temporal changes
in kenya
many apologies that i cannot be with you
today as i'm teaching and thanks for
indulging me in this opportunity to
record a short film
my name is dr matthew davis and i work
at the institute for global prosperity
at university college london and most of
my research has focused on how people
manage
agricultural landscapes in eastern
africa and i briefly like to introduce a
long-standing
multi-disciplinary research project that
has examined food systems
in mariquette in northwest kenya this is
led by a number of co-investigators
including the pi professor henrietta
moore
dr wilson kip corey from the university
of aldrat
professor jacqueline mcglade from
strathmore university and from ucl
and dr sam lun rockcliff from ucl who
should be with you all today
it also includes multiple east african
partners including the east africa
herbarium
and the british institute in eastern
africa
now mariquette is a rural area that
straddles the eastern side of the cario
valley
it's well known for its extensive
pre-colonial irrigation
systems and our research project has a
deep history led by professor moore with
some continuity go back going back into
the 1970s
and including work by kenyan scholars
such as ben kip courier
jason younger s matissio and wilson kip
corey
as well as researchers including bill
adams liz watson and ton dietz
throughout our research has intersected
with food systems and has often taken
these as the central focus
but it's also important to note that the
work has
also focused on many other related
issues particularly broader development
interventions
such as this red cross irrigation scheme
and wider processes of ecological
management
a key tenant of our research over the
last decade has been to develop
community-led research through citizen
scientists
who are community members and who who
helped determine the research questions
methods and analyses
this citizen science team is led by mr
timothy kippkayokit ruto
and miss helena cheptoe pictured here on
the left with one of our key team
members nelson valengo on the right
research into food systems by this team
has thus always been embedded in wider
social economic and environmental agenda
often defined by the priorities of the
citizen scientists and the community
itself
rather than by strict singular research
questions
for example lines of research have
examined failed histories of development
interventions
many of which have been agricultural in
nature but many of which also have not
a primary aim of this work has thus been
to build a detailed history of the
community the agricultural landscape the
rural economy and its wider connections
to food production which necessarily
form a core
aspect of this the methods employed have
been diverse but often rooted in
different ways of mapping and knowing
the wider landscape
and embedding analyses of things plants
animals pathways
networks buildings and interventions
within this landscape
so this work has included everything
from traditional archaeological field
survey
to surveys of colonial and postcolonial
structures and interventions
combined with multiple forms of
ethnographic observation and interview
spanning both his ethno-historical and
contemporary topics
particular attention has been paid to
physically but
to physically mapping with gps and gis
the landscape led by the citizen science
team
including mapping contemporary and
historic features in relation to food
production
settlement patterns field boundaries
irrigation
terracing erosion buildings and other
structures
participant-led mapping has planned
individual fields as you can see here
including their boundaries routes
pathways and allowing for detailed
in-situ ethnographic interviews of what
farmers produce
where when how and in what combinations
repeat mapping of nearly 100 film fields
over the last eight years in particular
has not only provided quantitative data
on the types and combinations of crops
both indigenous and hybrid but also for
deeper conversations about decision
making and
innovative experimentation
work on ethnobotany has thus been
extensive including identifying
the complex use of some different 10
varieties
of sorghum and 12 land race varieties of
finger millet
but we've always situated these in wider
systems of food production through time
and always focused on the intersection
of both indigenous land races
and more hybrid crops
most recently we've worked on
geo-referenced smartphone data recording
of
interviews features and photographs and
have developed with pharma's bespoke
data collection applications using a
software called sapele
that allows farmers to record cropping
practices and associated challenges
although these data are still being
collected and are still under analysis
this has resulted in some 29 major
cultivated crops being
um identified both new and old
with some 36 wild food plants and these
are used in
literally hundreds of unique
combinations
overall then although this work has
documented indigenous food production
the aim has not been to
focus solely on the heritage of this but
rather to try
to place diverse food production systems
within a complex narrative of change and
continuity through time and space
and to situate this within contemporary
food debates such as those surrounding
the notion of an african green
revolution
our aim i think has been particularly to
help smallholders
holder farmers show how diverse their
practices and influences are
and to situate their heritage alongside
the dynamic use of modern materials
ideas and experimentation
so in short then i think this our work
has been about rethinking the
distinctions between traditional
and modern practice between continuity
and innovation
and to recenter smallholder farmers
as sources of rather than as the
recipients of innovation
so i hope that this quick talk has not
been too brief
and too confused but i thank you all
very much for listening
and hope to hear feedback and questions
through the grapevine thank you very
much brilliant thanks
when we move on to um questions after i
think you could all see the the comment
from
from sam here in the chat so sam's with
us today so
he can address um questions and he's
also posted a longer version of that
video
um so now we're going to move on to
to sandeep hazard singh from open
university
who's going to talk about oral history
is a method for studying
the meaning of food waste in india thank
you
thank you deliver so this this talk is
based on recorded and filmed oral
history
interviews with women small holders in
karnataka india in the context of a
recent
ahrc-funded collaborative project called
changing farming lives in south india
past and present from this experience
and in the context of our discussion of
food systems and heritage oral history
might provide
a particularly amenable entry point for
research
this is because oral history is about
memory and remembering lived experience
it can therefore document and
communicate food traditions and heritage
and the meanings and feelings involved
in a particularly vivid manner
secondly food tends to resonate
particularly well with memory
in terms of its sensorial ability to
trigger
rich memories and emotions of food
pleasures
within home family and community
this process is known as edible memory
thirdly this method offers the
capability of generating insights
into meanings of food cultures over
a significant historical duration
um and it is also
finally conducive to reclaiming the
voices and life experiences
of indigenous and sub-altern groups such
as
women presents and farmers who tend to
be
marginalized in written documents
oral history essentially involves a
process
of co-creation between interviewer
and narrator in a way that both
highlights narrator agency and
invites listeners or viewers into
her lived experience
very often in development writings the
voices of
subaltern groups tend to be subsumed by
the researchers interpretation
which is what ultimately becomes
authoritative
in our project we began by asking
questions that of course were primarily
of interest to us as researchers
but participants were encouraged to
shape their narratives
as much as they wished by talking about
food crops food activities
other subjects and life episodes that
they themselves regarded
as significant and meaningful
in the process uh we discovered that it
was foods
and diets that the women's smallholders
were particularly passionate about
especially the beliefs rituals and
knowledges
associated with finger millet based food
ways
that they were seeking to revive
rituals involved deities earth seeds
animals birds and other more than human
entities
which have the power to affect food and
farming outcomes
in contrast they were much less
interested in the economic specificities
of crops and livelihoods
so just to conclude i would say that
oral history offers the capacities to
understand
and change the present in the light of
the past
to identify patterns of local social and
climate change
to give voice to hidden and alternative
narratives
and finally to recall cultural memories
as a repository of knowledge and
resilience
for ongoing innovations thank you
thanks sandy that's brilliant um and uh
so we've just got one last uh video now
um from harriet's cooling
um who some of you might remember from
monday
um and she's talking about participatory
methods
for exploring indigenous food systems
health and well-being
thank you for including me in this
segment of the
of the program that you have developed
there at
q and i i ed i'm very happy
to be with you to be talking about
participatory methods
to explore indigenous peoples food
systems
health and well-being so my experience
is through the center for indigenous
peoples nutrition and environment
at mcgill university in montreal canada
where i was founding director
from 1985 until 2009
and i'm still active in promoting the
center
as which is really why i'm here today
so i have to give credit to many many
people who
worked through the center over the years
and our community collaborators
not only for the data that we have
provided in the many publications
but also for building the strategies
for community consultation when we
started our work with the center we had
the indigenous leaders in canada guiding
us
on how to have proper community
consultation
and in fact they even lobbied for
funding with the canadian government to
help establish the center
so we're very grateful to them in
particular to chief bill erasmus
from the denny nation so our work
in the canadian arctic during that
period of time
led to many publications
but i want to call your attention to
this publication
that uh was requested from the w.h.o
[Music]
this was published in 2003 in english
and spanish
it's on the cine website as well as the
whole website indigenous peoples and
participatory
health research planning management and
preparing research agreements
so we learned that there is no one
single way to build collaboration
every community is different but there
are a few
key principles uh but i'd like to call
your attention to
first of all you have to listen you have
to learn
know how to carefully listen to your
collaborators in the communities for
their concerns
for their ideas on how to do things
right
from their perspective so that means you
have to maintain a respect
for the people and that helps them
respect you
you need respect for the food system the
environment
and work uh to continue to build mutual
respect for mutual benefit
so that leads to the important concept
of trust
you can't get anywhere in community work
with research or development
without having mutual trust with your
community
so one of those principles means you're
working with them
you're not working on them you're not
working on nutrition
on the people in x community you're
working with them
so i also call your attention to the
2016 publication
from fao on free prior and informed
consent
and please always recognize that you
need collective as well as
individual consent in the research
processes
and along the line uh always keep in
mind that when
we as academics prepare our publications
it is very important for the community
partners
to know about them to participate in
them to be co-authors
and to have these publications returned
to them so that they can be translated
if appropriate for
the community members i think that's all
i have time for
thank you very much okay so
um now we i think we're doing
we're perfectly on time um
so we can have some 10 minutes for
questions um i'm just trying to get my
speaker view back on great so has anyone
got any questions for anyone
you can raise your your hands or put
questions in the chat
excellent so i see quite a lot of
comments in the the chat box but i think
they're
i haven't been able to follow those
doing all of this i think
they're from the previous discussions so
does anyone have any
questions for the recent speakers of the
flash talks
lucas hello everyone my name is lucas
pavera and
i'm researcher combining ethnobotanical
and nutrition approaches
and with the indigenous partnership and
mr frank roy who is present we are
working on indigenous food systems in
indonesia northeast india and also a bit
in ethiopia and
mexico yucatan and uh i would like to
mention the presentation of dr tiziano
which was
i think this livelihood aspect is
becoming more and more important
and as we can see many indigenous
cultures and also the food systems are
under pressure
and changing from the intensification
livelihood needs
and also cash crops coming so i think
the livelihood aspect
is really that's something that should
be strengthened
but what we found is quite a challenge
is how do we balance the trade-off
between livelihood and commercialization
and also own consumption for example
in indonesia or northeast india our
studies are showing that
farmers are producing nutritious food
groups
such as eggs or fruits but then they
rather
you know sell them because of the income
opportunities
which a little bit compromised the diets
and dietary diversity in the end
so you know how do we balance this this
trade-off between livelihood and owned
consumption
that would be my question and yeah thank
you
yeah thank you lucas for your very
interesting question
is actually a key question and i think
um
you know it is very important in terms
of development
and how to carry out the sustainable
development as you are
mentioning the problem is that you can
support livelihood
you can help commercializing one species
but how can we stop by
somehow how can bring the benefit into
the community
it's key and naturally it needs to be
involved into the value chain
of that product and of course uh
again this need to be multi-disciplinary
and also involve different stakeholders
and it's important to have uh even um
some
um like a at the country level some
legislation
that uh uh in a way that is need
it's incorporated into the legal
framework of the country
uh because otherwise you need to to
protect this product and actually
more in the value chain you have a
middle dealer
more likely um less likely you're going
to
benefit the local community and so it's
really a big problem
and i think it's something that we're
always being
aware through our work and through our
research
and uh for this we've been really
working directly with the local
community and
and also with hgo because ngos somehow
they are
the voice in general of the local
community and they really can help us
in bringing the commercialization
and from the community to the national
regional level
national level and potentially at the
international level
so this is definitely a key step in
order to
support livelihood they need to be
addressed and this
again you need to be in the
interdisciplinary and design
at the same time to have a multi um
participatory approach not only at the
research level but also
by linking up with with the
local government and national government
at the same time
thank you
brilliant thank you um so i've got a
couple of questions here
paul's in the chat first and then on to
roger
so how widespread is the pattern of
farmers selling production to the
detriment of their nutrition
sandy do you have any comments on that
um i think the
the women farmers we spoke to actually
very keen on the nutritional aspects of
uh
the foods they were they were seeking to
revive
um they were kind of very aware that
it was particularly important to know to
to grow
known foods and that there was no
benefit
in consuming foods from the outside as
they put it which they did not know
so this issue of knowledge um
of foods was particularly important um
and they were able to tell us in detail
in in
in in a considerable way the uh
nutritional properties
of uh foods like uh the various millets
which uh they were growing um
and and and and the worst properties of
the seeds they
they they were saving and exchanging
as well um
that's that's great thanks and i
remember
something from some of my interviews as
well that just things like qualities of
taste could change when
certain crops growing for food were
growing different qualities of soils and
it's that
very sort of precise local knowledge and
so sometimes you could have the same
crop being grown in some different soils
for purposes of selling that crop or
for using it for animal fodder then the
same crop from the same
like land race being grown in a
different patch of better quality soils
when it was being
used to eat at home so and that sort of
knowledge was being lost sort of locally
as well
um so roger you had a question as well
um i've been a surprise this conference
is
sort of entitled indigenous food systems
there's been extraordinary little
discussion of cookery itself and then
you know actual actual ways that people
think about
preparing different foods now in
etanagar
in the capital of arunachal pradesh one
of the fascinating things are the tribal
food restaurants that's what they call
the many different ethnic groups in 52
in arunachal pradesh
many have their own quite specific
cuisines
and they have a restaurant system which
has grown up to serve people
who want to eat those particular foods
i there's you know this sort of thing
also happens a bit in nigeria and
quite a lot in indonesia where in
indonesia
any big city has restaurants which serve
people from different islands
in indonesia i feel these are grossly
understudied in other words these are
some of the
institutions these commercial
restaurants which are acting to
propagate indigenous food systems
in other words they're the people who
who make money from actually
selling people the food they really like
to eat and uh
to my knowledge i've seen very little or
no study of any sort of
these these restaurant systems and how
they actually promote indigenous foods
has anyone else got any um comments on
that
but raj yeah i was to say thank you
roger that's a very good point i've
i think recipes and dishes and cookery
is extremely important we've
had students looking at the
reintroduction of wild plants
into these kinds of restaurant cuisines
in malaysia for instance in singapore
and because of covet 19 here in london
in malaysian restaurants
and looking also that that these places
are
also venues to revitalize
traditional crops and traditional plants
um
plants in cooking as a as also
a way to kind of present that
traditional food tradition
yeah and philip i also wanted to add on
that
uh yeah i think it's extremely important
to uh to record a recipe and it's
somehow a way to conserve the way in in
the same way you can solve the recipe or
conserving the traditional
you are conserving the species as well
and i wanted to mention that
we have recently started a project on
the mediterranean diet
in lebanon and jordan and we identify
some species that actually you can't
find in the
um in the lebanese restaurant in orlando
you know they really
consider a delicacy at the country level
and really really appreciate them
so the world we are doing is really
trying to bring these other species some
are harvested
from the wild some are cultivating and
we're also looking into the nutritional
content of the species looking at the
micronutrients
in order to to look at the health
benefits
and at the same time by looking at the
health benefit you can
this information can help to promote
these species that are minor in the
cuisine somehow or
what we know outside but they're still
very important at the local level
that's brilliant julian did you have
your hand up before
one of the things is that um yes i agree
with
roger blench and raj and the thing is
that
another dimension i just forgot to
mention is that
you know we've been talking about plant
and seed collections and all these types
of things but also
one of the things that i do in order to
be able to inform
and like identify foods from the
archaeological record is that i have a
food library
not just of the recipes but actually
pieces of the food because um
you know you can have the recipes you
can have all these things but if you
don't know how does the product really
look um and that also helps you inform
and understanding how these types of
like um
the the way that the method
conditions the type of behavior that the
remain will have
so that's another thing that you can
actually be doing you have been
you know i i know that every time you go
to the field work you are like oh here
eat this eat that
and then you can just try and build up
also a food reference collection
which would be it's it's one of the
important aspects
i think is oh i've got one quick
comment so like as archaeobotanists were
always interested in those stages of
processing and
i think one thing we're looking at
changes in the last 50 years
that sort of research sandeep's been
doing with
looking at grinding stones
and moving to modern methods in the same
in sudan is that
sometimes the changing cooking practices
or use of crops is
is linked to these changing material
cultures and
so when when interest in our our project
is looking from
farm through to plate to try and capture
all those interconnected processes
so alex you had you had a question
um yeah so i hi i'm alex i'm at the
ucl institute of archaeology and rachel
botanist i also intern
for q um i grew up on
coastal miwok land in northern
california i'm in communication
a lot with a lot of native tribes in
california through different dialogue
groups
what chumash serrano washu miwok
and um something that we talk a lot
about is
reconnecting with traditional recipes
and how do we support
indigenous groups who have been forced
out of practicing traditional food
systems
and the increased rise in this i don't i
don't really hear a lot of discussions
with traditional native americans in
north america
a lot of people have are in urban
settings or on reservations
but there is an increased interest with
the rise of like indigenous people's day
which was this past monday
as a replacement for columbus day with a
desire to reintegrate traditional
food systems even though the the origins
of a lot of
american food systems are actually like
in the narrative like thanksgiving
how do we support communities of people
who are
have had broken indigenous condition
traditions because a lot of my friends
who are miwok or
honey want to practice these recipes
they want to reintegrate
a corn flour into the dialogue they want
to
integrate traditional like you know
um fishing practices but they don't have
any resources
to do that and so but there is an
increased commercial interest in it like
the sioux cookbook has picked up
and has won a national award and so
there is like an increasing fascination
with native american cuisines but
there's
next to no support so i don't know i
don't know i just wanted to bring this
into the dialogue and i wanted to um
kind of introduce a north american
perspective just because they're often
um not included in the dialogue does
anyone have any
comments on that um and there's actually
some related comments now
in the chat as well but and then we're
going to have to move on to a
break i think if you look at gary
navain's work
uh on food networks and food sovereignty
in the
southwest and uh west of the united
states
food heritage systems and trying to
reclaim traditional food
food waste
can i also mention that way back in the
end of the 19th century
the good old smithsonian used to produce
wonderful books
about indigenous cookery systems in
north america
books which are long out of print but in
my view
you know people should have a look at
these because they
documented food and cookery systems at a
time where they were pretty well
intact i mean i collected a few of these
in myself but but you know but how are
these being distributed to communities
because my my friends i talk to don't
know these exist
slash they're often really hesitant to
engage with this literature because it
was often written by colonists
and so there's an apprehension to engage
is there access to resources that have
been written by indigenous scholars
because that's the biggest comment i get
from people i talk to
is how do i access modern day resources
written by indigenous ecologists or
people who have a comprehensive
understanding and it's not through a
colonial narrative because i know people
who know the smithsonian stuff but they
don't want to read it
because it's automatically comes from a
perspective that doesn't have a full
appreciation
that's this is just i'm just
regurgitating news i've i've been told
to spread from my communities so
yeah well i think that's really unfair
i've read this stuff and and these were
ex at least you could you need to look
at them and read them and see
are are they realistic and so on i mean
you know
of course maybe there is some colonial
perspective
but give them a chance don't just throw
them out of the
the pram all automatically
it's it's something that we have to deal
with with a lot of archival
material from from these periods and the
historical research methods take
take those sorts of biases into
consideration so you could try and
abstract the information but in the
context of those
materials but sandy could be able to to
better comment on
whether i've got that sort of correctly
phrased
uh well yeah yes if uh
if you're looking for kind of indigenous
or supporting voices
within within the within the archive
especially the colonial archive
uh you're likely to to look in vain
but nonetheless within that they
are um even the colonial archive
required um
reliance on native and indigenous
informants
so kind of a a way of reading the
archives
as has been called against the grain
will kind of give you some perspectives
from the people who provided the
colonialists with
the information so it's kind of a
fine reading the archives and being
alive to the kind of
the silences the dissonances
the information that is coming to
the colonial author and which is
sometimes actually acknowledged so
yes you would not get kind of a
clear a clear
outline of views directly by indigenous
or subaltern groups but
there is a way of making sense of of the
archives
they're not completely i would say
useless
and maybe that's the role of modern day
i'm afraid you're gonna have to stop now
i'm really sorry but please do continue
sorry i'm afraid we're gonna have to
stop now because we've run out of time
um we we scheduled a break from 12 30 to
quarter to
one which is only 15 minutes and i think
people will need some lunch before the
next
session it's been really fascinating and
i'm really glad roger brought up the
issue of food because
it's such a critical issue and i've
really enjoyed all the presentations
and all the discussion so thank you
really very much philippa and everybody
and uh please come back in in 15 minutes
right welcome back everyone
um i hope you managed to get some some
lunch so um
we're now gonna have a panel on
decolonizing and indigenous research
methods
and i just um want to thank you all for
your presentations
earlier they were so interesting i think
um
just a brief comment while we wait for
people to come back
the issue of intellectual property
rights that came up
um i think what harriet kuhnlein
said in her video about collective free
prior informed consent is really really
critical for ensuring that communities
know fully the risks of
commercialization
um before they agree to publish or to
disseminate
their knowledge and there's also the
option of
them not publishing and then building a
knowledge base within communities
and that's something we'll hear about in
this session
um i also was really enjoyed listening
about oral histories
and i think they have huge potential at
the moment because
um you know the loss of um
traditional knowledge that's going on is
often just the elders who have the
knowledge and so
oral histories are really important to
bring back
and revitalize by a cultural heritage in
in the areas we're working
you know to try and establish
biocultural heritage territories
uh i think archaeobotany um you know
might also help on that
if it can help with the recent past um
which is kind of more relevant and
immediate to communities and might still
have
um remnants in the memories of the
elders
the session now is um
is is a panel of indigenous people on a
topic which i think is really
important and as a researcher i think
that the best way
um to help indigenous peoples is to
ensure research is led by them
that it empowers indigenous peoples and
that address addresses their needs and
priorities
um and this type of research can have a
lot more impact
in terms of development and environment
impact than externally led research
and also there are ethical issues i
think
with externally led research um
you know you're asking indigenous
peoples to contribute to a process
which generally doesn't give them much
benefit in return so in my view that's
unethical um so i think this issue of
decolonizing
research methods is really really
important and
i would like to introduce um professor
chi baguela chilisa
i hope you're here with us so
um she is a professor at the university
of botswana
and her work has focused on on
culturally and contextually responsive
research
and evaluation and she's written a
brilliant book on indigenous research
methodologies
so welcome and thank you so much baguela
you have 10 minutes
or ten okay thank you thank you so much
thank you for having me
um this has been a wonderful
uh time for me i've had a lot of
interesting things from all the
presenters
and now is in this 10 minutes i'm going
to share with you
uh uh what i have so
my focus is going to be on uh indigenous
research methodologies
and what they are and their benefit
to doing research on indigenous
uh indigenous food
so indigenous research methodologies is
about
the right of those whose voices have
been
silenced by western knowledge
to know to talk
and to be heard
while for example in academics may use
historical data as you have heard over
over the last two days
indigenous people can talk
and be heard by
using for example foreclose
stories taboos about food
oral traditions about food names of food
songs about food
that is a way to give the indigenous
people
voice of course the scientists can
always
do archival data
i mean archaeological data and do
all the sciences but
indigenous people also have the right to
know
and they know and they know through
those methods
it is about indigenous people's right
to know to produce knowledge
and all knowledge
in wasana when we fry potatoes
we call them french fries and i think
the world over they are called french
fries even when they
are fried in the u.s that
talks about an indigenous
french recipe
indigenous research methodologies is
about
bringing indigenous knowledge to the
global market
bringing those indigenous recipes
to the global market so that they can
compete
with other recipes
it has it is about
the right to place indigenous
ways of knowing
and values at equal footing
with other knowledge systems when we
talk indigenous research methodologies
we are therefore talking about mixed
methods
where mixed methods is not only about
combining quantitative and qualitative
data but it is also about
combining indigenous knowledge
indigenous
methods with a
other conventional methods
so that when we talk of indigenous
research methodologies
we're talking about collaborative
research
we are talking about multiple methods
that recognize indigenous
methods indigenous knowledge is a
indigenous recessional methodologies is
about
the right of indigenous people to
prioritize
the research agenda and participate
in what is recess
and to be recognized as core knowledge
producers when you talk about
prioritizing
we are talking we are talking about the
relevant research
of course western researchers have been
luxury
just to research for curiosity's sake
we indigenous people don't have that we
need a research that can benefit
us and it is uh it is us
who can prioritize what is relevant
indigenous research is about the
resistance to stereotypes
and deficit theorizing perpetuated
by western knowledge western research
colonial research the archives
archived knowledge that continue to
perpetuate
stereotypes i can understand when
indigenous people say but who wrote
those reports
who wrote those recipes in those books
that talk about
indigenous people from what perspective
did they write
them did they write about those recipes
as recipes and food
that is not only for eating but it is
also for
for spirituality it's also for
well-being
it is also for connecting people with
the environment
when they refuse to say no not those you
have to understand that
they're probably taken from a point of
the world
views
a point of their own world views
so indigenous research methodologies is
not about
replacing conventional methods
with indigenous research methodologies
it is about a coalition of knowledge
systems
a coalition that
recognizes other knowledge systems on
equal footing
it is about
decolonizing the minds of them
indigenous people you know indigenous
people
they have been brainwashed
to think that their foods are inferior
it is therefore about indigenous people
appreciating their own heritage
where for example they recognize
indigenous recipes
indigenous foods as food that can
compete
in the global market
indigenous research methodologies is
about
carrying out research informed by
indigenous world views
ways of perceiving reality and
value systems
those marginalized by western knowledge
for example can begin by
valuing the indigenous field conducting
community research to remind people
about the nutritional value of their
foods
and that's the spiritual healing of the
i i happen to
listen to a presentation by one of the
students who had
who was talking about food security in
part of the country
and one of the things that came out was
that
there were some indigenous foods that
could
help that could stand the vagaries of
the climate
much much better than those
uh of uh uh crops that have been
borrowed from the west however
the people were not willing to grow
indigenous crops because they've been
brainwashed
to think that eating rice is better than
eating local
food
in research on indigenous foods that in
that use an indigenous perspective
indigenous methodologies as i said
before
it appreciates
the value of food not
only for quenching hunger
but also for spirituality purposes
for connection with the land
an indigenous research worldview
recognizes spirituality that is not
talked about
in western research
and for you therefore it will be
appropriate
to research on indigenous food
using an indigenous world view
that goes beyond western
ways of perceiving reality
to indigenous ways of seeing reality
spirituality also is reality
to say that research has to respect
indigenous values is to talk about
eight hours
that is the art of relationality
this is ethic ethics the ethics of
research
includes relationality which is
doing research that is long-lasting
you build relationships with the people
not helicopter research where you where
where you get in and get out as quickly
as possible
it's about respect that is respecting
the values of the people
respecting their voices giving them a
chance to participate
is about responsity what is it what is
this research
giving back this documentation
and databases what are they giving back
to the communities
is it okay to archive those in the form
of documents
knowledge that that has that that the
researcher
got from the the communities while the
communities are hungry
researchers can build their names with
the research this and that
but what are you giving back to their
communities it's about
responsible research responsible
research is to say
whose research is it who am i for
as a researcher you always come up with
a point of view
you come into the search with a world
view whose world
view are you using are you looking at
the researcher
as somebody who doesn't know who you are
helping because you can get funding from
some sponsor elsewhere or are you only
are you are you getting funds so that
you can work with the researchers
not for curiosity not to do research for
curiosity
but to do research that is relevant
for us there is an urgent need for
research that
addresses our problems not research for
curiosity
of the people to prioritize their
research agenda
when you now say you are coming up with
this and that
is that your priority as a researcher or
is that the priority
of the people reverence people are
indigenous people are very spiritual
do you respect their spirituality
responsiveness as you do research are
you able
to to respond to the immediate
needs to the changes as you go along and
you do the research
or do you use book research where you
say
according to uh this author
this is how it has to be done therefore
i can't
change i can't do that i can't do that
reflexivity
as you do research do you reflect upon
yourself
and say what uh what what are the kind
of stereotypes and prejudices
that i bring into this community do you
reflect
and lastly decolonization
the ethics is ethics when it
also decolonizes research and to
decolonize research
is to allow other people to speak from
their
own point of view their own
world views thank you very much
oh thank you so much uh professor
chilisa that was um
brilliant um those eight r's i think are
really useful principles for all
research um does anybody have any
questions
because we have just a couple of minutes
and then we'll
move on to the next one
i can't see any questions um
i think we're all absorbing just a quick
thing i think
um you know she hit the nail
on the there needs to be a reverence
to the knowledge that it's being
produced
because at times um you know this is
something that also i
i kind of like talk about that there's
food that it's of nutrition or value
that is good for you but there's like
good for your well-being and that's
something important that at times
get get doesn't come through the
research
um and especially with at least i work
in the caribbean and
the indigenous communities there are not
recognized so
and there's all these ideas of they were
all exterminated
during the colonial times so their
practices and spiritualities that are
still active and
also by recognizing them from a research
point of view
we are also giving them the agency
and the recognition that they deserve
outside
of their own circles
um thank you so much i have one question
i am missing one of the r's
could we have a list
is relationality respect
responsibility responsibility
rights reverence responsiveness
reflexivity and decolonization
thank you so much i think you know you
remind us that we all have our own
worldview researchers they see what what
they see
through their own lens they don't
document the spirituality because it's
not part of their own culture
so we need to leave our culture behind
and step into
and see things and be guided by your
worldview
so that we can do the research properly
but anyway thank you so much and um
we'll have hopefully a bit more time for
discussion later but that was wonderful
i'd like now to pass on to um
uh so florence um daggy tan
she's from the philippines and um
to briefly introduce she is a
um
[Music]
is one of the seven ethnic linguistic
groups
known as the igarots in the cordillera
of the northern philippines
and she's going to talk about indigenous
methods for research on agri-food
systems in the philippines
she's also working at teb tebber
good evening everyone it's
it's i think eight o'clock in our in our
area so i say
good evening or good noon good afternoon
i'm happy to be here and
i thank i thank also the opportunity for
me to speak
on our experience i'm speaking as an
indigenous person
who has also gone to the academic world
but my res my involvement in the
research
in the search for appropriate research
methodologies
comes from a being part of uh of a
people's movement
first from the advocates of the organic
agriculture sustainable farming
ecological agriculture agroecology
things like that and then second as an
advocate for the promotion of indigenous
people's
rights for for its fulfillment and
respect
so from the very start of my work
just upon my college days because that
was so much activism in the philippines
that was the time of march alone
we were fortunate enough to be given uh
the correct orientation of working
for the people and with the people
so uh so we were taught
that our people indigenous peoples in
the era
or indigenous peoples of the world
create and produce knowledge from their
day-to-day life
as they relate with their nature and the
land
the monitor changes events places
they closely observe what is in their
surroundings
and discover new ways of doing things
whatever they discover they share to
whoever is interested in the community
like a better way of restoring the seeds
the part of the forest where such trees
can be found
and others this knowledge
are shared in various ways in different
venues and these are stored in stories
epics songs chants
in the memories of our people but they
are shared
very or orally and this
we have this in in at present today
so we see that people have been creating
knowledge and
producing knowledge yet
when we go to the communities and invite
some group
to do a research or
because we were also told that to to
work in the community
you have to start where the people are
so we have to do the research but if we
invite
some groups to do that research with us
then they will say oh if it's research
it's not for us it's for the school
people
those who come from the academy or those
who went to the universities
so we see a manifestation of
the colonized research in our lands also
uh
uh even at this time
so the first challenge that we need to
transcend
is to reiterate that people themselves
are doing their own research and
creation of knowledge
in their day-to-day life
in this event i would like to share
some of the effective indigenous
research methods
that we have that that we do to
especially in doing research in
agri-food systems
and when i'm when i was writing this it
seems they are very much
uh i think all of you knows this it's
just a matter of saying it
so one is the mapping
or walking through our territory which
is the
essay which is the sense of place and
identity for
us so in the mapping some of the many
things that we can
draw or generate from the mapping
exercise or walking through our
territories
is are the diversity of the food crops
the different kinds of food crops in the
cultivated area
we we can list as many as 40 kinds
with each kinds of different varieties
so you see
hundreds of varieties of food crops in
our
cultivated crops but we can also see the
location
of the naturally occurring wild plants
and animals
that are part of of the people's diet
how the whole territory contributes to
the community's diet
we can also locate the abode of the
unseen
because these are very important to us
they have to have a share of the food
but when you look deeper into it
it has so much a lot to do with the
conservation of the
species or the regeneration of species
like one one belief is that
if there is one bamboo shoot you should
not be taking it
because it's for the spirits or it's for
the unseen
and if you if you look at that in the
scientific language then you will say
that's for the regeneration so that
something will come out again and
reproduce itself
and in the sacred sites or are also the
abode of our spirits
uh you cannot go and hunt there so it's
a sanctuary for the science also
for us it's about of the unseen who are
our companions in our territory
but i think for scientists it's the
sanctuary of fauna and flora
so they appreciate it very much but they
will say
we are superstitious if we say we do not
go there because it's the mode of the
spirit
and in the mapping we did some upgrading
so we also build their capacity to use
the gps
and also to build the 3d map so that
then they can always come back to their
map
and talk about the things that we'd like
to talk
the second methodology is the use of
traditional calendar
it shows the availability of the food at
what time of the year
the time to plan and the time to harvest
the time not to disturb the wild animals
in the forest
the fishes in their iceland the fishes
in the rivers
because this is the time for them to
mate and reproduce
again and the indicators of changes in
the weather
the third methodology is storytelling
it can show certain food how certain
food are valued
and why it can show changes
in the consumption and production
pattern of our people
how the wilds are protected and how
seeds are conserved
and how seeds are exchanged
it can it can show also why we do
certain rituals
especially in our rice land every step
of our every stage of the production
cycle of the rice land we do retails
so then our elders will
explain why we have to do those rituals
and then the compare and contrast
method how commu how community elders
and leaders
are more proactive in the past than in
the present because of the assimilation
that is ongoing to us
and how they were able to cope with food
scarcity and farming
the other is uh but now we rely on the
government
sometimes we we forget that we have our
own
uh ways of or our own self-reliance
the other is the other method is the
learning by doing
when we do innovations in in our farming
system
like production of organic farm inputs
and if this is the
these are the times that we call
sometimes we call on scientists to help
us here
like uh soil testing of of soil tests
if we do a production of we use our
resources to produce fertilizers
and we also use modern technology and
to face and decomposition things like
that so we call on the scientists to
help us with the laboratory work
of if our soils are improving if the
insects are more diverse insect
population
and then we also test the traditional
indicators
like for alkaline soil they say that
sour
and for acidic they say it's they taste
it as
bitter so we can test that in the
laboratory
it's not validation but i think it's in
also enriching
and then that you one of the actual
things too is the
cooking of traditional crops
results and outcomes comes even
as early as uh it depends on what you
are
researching or studying
but but the most the most essential part
is the collective analysis
it's one of the most essential process
which may lead to fall
policy formulation like comparing and
contrasting the food
of the past and the present and the
health of the children
and then they will say oh let's ban the
junk food
but it will also have to have a
commitment
from the women to retrieve the
traditional food that they used to have
as a snacks things like that uh
yeah and then it can also lead to action
like
reviving the our backyard gardens things
like that
for those are the things that we do and
then
for recommendation yeah of course
full and effect if if it's an outsider
who is coming to our communities
the full and effective participation of
the community should be first
insured and then
yeah also indigenous peoples have also
come
to do their community research and they
should be supported
and to also build our capacities
and more important is to aya
i think more important is that research
should be an educational process for the
facilitator
and the communities and that the output
of research like the knowledge produced
should be first should first benefit the
community
for me also i still find it uh an
internal conflict
on publishing
yeah because sometimes uh funders
would like publishing but for me it will
not matter if you publish or not but it
matters very much
that what has the community learned and
what actual
what awareness has been created and what
actions have been
done because of that research process
and of course
uh i know also that we indigenous while
we have this
yeah profound wisdom things like that
but we also have to work
with other collaborators thank you very
much
oh thank you so much florence that was
really great
and um it was really interesting to
learn about your methods
um about the mapping and so on
storytelling
um we have a little bit of time if
anybody would like to
ask a question or make a comment
um this is sanjukta gosh from the soy
south asia institute i'm a historian
and researcher on agricultural knowledge
my question is really related to the
methods
in indigenous knowledge that we just
heard
and i was curious to know you know who
guards these agricultural calendars
that you were talking about is it still
with the elders
or is it also something that the
young and the women are involved in um
and and how is you know agricultural
calendar is again
very based on a very long-term
understanding
of how seasons work and how crops and
animals behave
so i'm just curious how you're building
in
this whole notion of climate change with
a more traditional
agricultural calendar that is in place
so are these things taken into account
when you're changing practices or
whether you're
creating new calendars uh that's just
something i had in mind yeah
yeah thanks very thank you for the
question
uh at present actually in in the areas
that i have gone
climate change is actually uh
in it does not fit in their calendar so
it's uh for them also for the for our
elders
there's also uh because
when they follow the rice cycle they
have indicators
like the coming of certain birds the
flowering of certain crops
and they cannot uh many times they
cannot see it anymore
and so and then also the coming of
varieties that those are all those are
also taken into consideration
but uh so
so they say how how do we deal how do
they deal with that but
from from the stories that i heard it
says they
more and more they do not rely on the
the indicators on the changing season
but more and more they rely on dreams so
uh
but but then also if uh because that
calendar also synchronizes
the activities right and it has a lot of
to do of labor allocation
pest control management so our elders
are actually grappling
with this change erratic changes in
weather and season
yeah so that's that's one of the
challenge that we need
also to have collaborative work
with scientists
great thank you so much is there any
other question
for florence or comment
or other sharing from others
yeah i mean i have to say florence
and both and baguel it so much of what
you said resonated with
what i know um from indigenous research
methods
in in the andes um in the potato park
and maize park
and there's there's a lot of similarity
um because i didn't know about you know
the
the ones florence and the philippines
and but the
the mapping by walking through the
landscape
through the territory and um
and storytelling um
and and many of the principles that both
of you talked about
i seem to be quite universal in terms of
you know being important for indigenous
communities being useful
something that's useful directly to you
um
was emphasized by both of you
um right
so um i don't know if anybody else wants
to make any comment feel free to jump in
and just share your
thoughts or reactions
but not also question when i was talking
and now
i think also the elders are
triangulating
like their dreams their the
the changes the indicators of seasons
and then where the sun strikes in the
morning
yeah because these are the the things
that lead them to
declare this is that we start the season
of planting
thank you so much florence it was really
brilliant
okay well in that case um we should
probably
jump to um alejandro's presentation
alejandro are you with us
i think i just saw you good morning
good morning so to introduce alejandro
um he is the person who did all the
translation for the potato park session
um from quechua to english he's um
director of programs at the swift
foundation
and he's a board member of association
andes
and an indigenous quechua leader and
advisor to the potato park
and coordinator of inmit the
international network
of mountain indigenous peoples and he's
going to talk about the decolonizing
methodologies that the ngo andes has
developed with the potato park
and the maize park communities uh please
go ahead alejandra
thank you christina and good morning
everyone
from my side um it's
um it's a pleasure and an honor to
participate in this
panel um with
so distinguished practitioners
and activists and intellectuals
all individuals
so my greetings um
i wanted to share a few slides because
for us visuals
dreaming
imagining envisioning captures
this very intimate
relationship that we have with time with
a space
and it encapsulates those dreams
that we continue to have and
the picture you see is well known as
machu picchu but it
epitomizes what in digital research
can do this is
the an expression of a
holistic approach
to how ontologies
and epistemologies can produce
uh what we call sumacaosa or wendy beer
holistic living machu picchu is a
very um
intricate all shows a very intricate
relationship between
you know water management
so high knowledge of hydraulics
engineering architecture
mechanics physics
but above all it shows this
relationship with
deep respect with the environment and i
think in a current crisis
and all these pressing socioeconomical
political
and ecological challenges that we are
facing this type of knowledge
it has become very important in terms of
how we can weep new tomorrows
so in our part of the world we are a
product of
like you see much much richer as a
indigenous scholars
looking for uh
reaching this goal of wendy beer
so this embodies uh
spirituality a relationship with the
natural world
which is the cornerstone of this
conception
of knowledge and therefore the purpose
of research
is established there and
expressing principles and values um
we see in our
past how
this ontological and epistemic
principles
are embedded on
how our ancestors have passed all
knowledge to us
and our responsibility to
keep evolving to keep using this
knowledge
and evolving to respond to challenges of
via
the future key principles here
are relationality
initial result research methodologies is
about
accountability with the rest of our
relations so it's not just about humans
it is reciprocity that reflects with the
relationship that we have among
all the living elements that um or
living
beings including rocks or air or
water and that
live within this
universe of us and
also reciprocity we call it ime
it's important in terms of research
because it
questions this positivistic colonial
worldview
that research is neutral
but we have to only provide
very informed consent as a manner of
establishing consensual relationship
when the relationship it's not
between humans only
and finally balance which is key to
sustainability
and how we seek to
create um a balanced world
within the natural and the human world
within this um as i said um
we have a a taxonomy that characterized
this
where we have three communities three
ideas
and our goal is when vivier
in terms of research methods
and learning approaches
i just want to highlight three of them
which are key to all the research
activities we do
yachai which means learning with a mind
yankai which means doing and learning
with your hands and munai which means
learning and doing with the heart any
type of
action has to be
carried out or developed within those
three
tools of learning and action
now in terms of decolonizing methods
that we apply participation based
in this reciprocal relationship
between people and the environment
is key to it with the leadership of
elders
where the knowledge transmission and the
participation
of youth is key to it
within this
we
continue to
[Music]
create tools that go beyond or
challenges this colonial view
that boxes individual research methods
and tools within the hermetic borders
of convention conventional qualitative
research
we are supposed according to that view
only able to use
storytelling community mapping
legends oral tools
that are key to one part of the research
but in our case in our case
we also use
tools that provide the metrics
to create data
which after can be
used to measure and provide
numerical results that
creates a better approaches to solving
local problems uh here you have an old
drawing of an in command
using the kipu
which in this side of the picture we
have translated
into a molecular key which is the same
approach the same format but it reflects
what is um what is
within each one of the i2 potatoes like
in in this case all
this type of uh
ranking different types of values
which we call hupana continues to be
used by women to rank
and create give numerical value
to different uses of medicinal plants or
other crops
this also supply in uh
assessing climate change for for
instance here
where we create um
hubs every 100 meters up in the mountain
to assess
population dynamics how
pests or crops are moving up
because of climate change this provides
again
using the same type of metals and tools
numerical results that then
we can use to create solutions
this has allowed us to
to harbor in the potato past in the case
of the potato park
a large number one of the largest in the
world of
uh potato collection
keep those potatoes continue to do
research in terms of participatory plant
breeding
or the
collection of these
varieties that are in dangers of
disappearing
and each multiplication and transfer to
other communities
so the focus of this as was the focus in
the inca time
continue to be how do we create
solutions
through food
also we apply to policy
no matter how
supposedly complicated um
this is an example of
how we um
[Music]
come into conclusions on an evaluation
on
crispr this new technology that's
flooring
many research institutions of the world
and being again the you know the silver
bullet that's gonna
create all these changes when we believe
that
um what we have within us uh
can be the doors to the future so
to finish um i know
i have like i'm passing my time um
this type of research can be perhaps
better
beyond itself is the colonizing
focus also it can be
conceptualized as some type of
indigenous
mixed method strategy that combines
qualitative and quantitative
research practices and responds
to this main objective of summa causa
which is the aspiration of our
communities
and this um as we see in the case of the
kippu
or a hupana we use the approp
the appropriate theoretical frameworks
to transform those
old tools into new ways of
keep learning and keep creating new
knowledge
so while
our research strategy and methods are
framed within
a colonial biocultural history
i think that the principles and values
that
are inherent to this practice
creates also the possibility of new
tomorrows
and a decolonized research
practice thank you
thank you so much alejandro that was
fascinating
it's um it's wonderful to hear about the
how your research combines the
qualitative and quantitative but all
within
the use of indigenous principles and
world views and for the goal of sumat
kausai which is
holistic well-being or buenbeved
i don't know if anybody would like to
ask a question i realize we have
one for the previous for florence as
well we can go back to in a minute
but for alejandro does anyone have any
questions or comments
um i i will then ask one if that's okay
um the the diagram you showed at the
beginning
alejandro with the um the principles
that you were talking about
maybe you could explain a little bit
where that diagram
what it is and where it's from because i
think that's
fascinating to learn about it for others
who don't know
which one christina santa cruz pachakuti
oh this is the diagram
um that um
um
was that capture
what was
expressed as an art and
a holistic art expression in the most
sacred temple
of cusco the quarry country of the
golden
temple and this
conceptual graphic um
this drawing came from an
indian chronicler who
was able to translate it into this
conceptual graphic uh in the mid 1500s
after um you know um
eur i mean the
europeans arrive in cusco
and um it basically
captures our you know space our
ontology our universe
where we conceptualize three communities
that interact reciprocate and try to
work together
towards achieving smart cause and those
communities
are the human community or the runa
which includes everything that
is not just human and humans
nurture and reciprocity so
domesticated crops animals
water anything that lives
around humans is considered runa
the other realm is the salja
or the wild so anything that
has its own world
like a wild biodiversity wild water
while when
whatever humans don't have control
it has its own community and the third
one which is
the critical one is the aoki
which reflects our
[Music]
connection with the sacred that's where
our ancestors
and the sacred principles that define
the epistemological
architecture of knowledge
are embedded so
these three communities have to work
together and the way of communicating
and seeking balances through the
sacred uh principle of reciprocity or i
need
and once that balance is achieved we
have reached suma causa so
could you show it to us briefly so
people know which one you're talking
about
please
i was referring to this to this
where um you had this
old drawing of santa cruz pachacuti
and uh you know if you see
uh the middle star that's the southern
cross
which in most indigenous uh
traditions is a sacred symbol
because it connects the sacred with
the human world it connects the um
you know we call it chicana it's like a
bridge
we breach all types of epistemologies
and
you know um generations and
and you know different types of
conceiving the world so is the key
of diversity and with that we have
the aoki iu this which is the sacred the
iu ayu which is the wild
and the runai you the human realm
and what is reciprocity as i said
um we achieved sumac outside so
you know this paradigm this concept of
sumatra
of course go beyond this idea of
sustainability
where um you know the economical
uh interests or it's viewed
upon an architecture that's that keeps
um pushing this capitalist
uh uh world view
of western the western world to the
infinite
how we keep destroying nature without
destroying
that's what sustainability means in
terms of
i think western mind so
we kind of challenge that with this
paradigm
uh and where the ethical aspects of
research
which are embedded in the spiritual
values of nature's peoples
are strongly reflected in the aokia
thank you oh thanks a lot for explaining
that
so the the old diagram from this
incur chronicler in in the
1500s now guides their
their research which is led by community
researchers
from each community in the potato park
and
um it's very much um
about traditional knowledge indigenous
knowledge transmission transmitting the
values
and transmitting the knowledge between
elders and youth
through the research process as
alejandro mentioned at the beginning
so it's a way of you know really
revitalizing these cultural values and
biocultural heritage using these ancient
principles uh from the incas
which i think it is a really nice um
example which i haven't seen others do
but um i would love to find
similar um you know graphics
and principles and concepts for other
indigenous peoples i think it would
really help
in revitalizing biocultural heritage
does anybody uh would anybody like to
share any reflections with alejandro
if not we can go back to florence's
question
okay so um
okay i mean if if people want to
continue
um you know want to comment on your
presentation anybody want to don't be
shy
okay we can always come back to
alejandro and to begin in the
conversation but
for now i'm gonna um look at this
question for florence
um uh panilla would you like to say your
question are you still with us
okay i'll read it out uh thank you
florence for the rich presentation when
you refer to the elders triangulation
i also see we can add the very long
timeline
they have to build their experiences on
they have observed
and interacting with their landscape for
so long and with so many perspectives
so it can never be com compensated with
other methods from science which is in
the best case
study one one fact
facto in long time series but many times
represents a snapshot in one dimension
okay so it's a comment and panilla would
you please
um explain that if you're still with us
because i didn't fully understand it
but i think pernilla is trying to say
that
uh because i mentioned that uh in the
age of
uh yeah on the triangulation i will
start first with that
because in the in in our when we do our
research
we found out that the when they declare
the season to one season to start they
make use of uh
when does some would there are places
where
at the at the first break of the
of the sunrise the sun strikes somewhere
and another is the the the indicators in
the change in weather around the
surroundings
and another is their dream so that now
we only hear that they more rely on
dreams
because uh changes are happening
and some of the indicators have
disappeared
and and also that of course
yeah something like that but what i what
i understood from bernie
is that because i mentioned
that with the age of this change in
climate
and erratic weather condition we may
need also support to hasten the
knowledge development
on how we are going to appropriate
our our calendar in the changing times
and so i think bernie is saying that we
may not be needing
other knowledge system because our
elders are there that's what i got from
her
comment right okay thank you very much
um i wonder if um something i
i thought might be really relevant to
others is to understand a bit better
um more specifically your methods of
research
alejandro so the capacity building
workshop
workshops for the indigenous research
experts
and then the the app that you use for
them to collect the data
and that goes straight to a database and
you can explain all this much better but
we've been talking a little bit about
documenting knowledge and databases and
how to build a knowledge base in
communities
and maybe you could explain your
methodology on that aspect
please me
how to integrate metrics
and make measurements
that reflect
better or more accurate
how and you know
we conceptualize the our own universe
in terms of its relationality
uh everything is connected to everything
so you cannot do research
um which is um you know books and
some type of speciality
um and how
the results of um you know this type of
um holistic approach or integrative
approach
where you have mixed methods working all
the time
can be captured and stored
so um we had and
develop a process by which
we tried in the first instance to
combine
the collection methods in terms of the
qualitative and quantitative approaches
without making these type of
distinctions
but rather looking the needs of
particular phenomena that
we may be interested in learning or
solving once we have
the tools that are uh
decided to gather information
then um we have created
ways visual ways of
um and capturing that type of
information which includes the use
now of an application that we have
developed
in-house that takes advantage
of the visuals that um
a um
you know
a phone
or a tablet these days may offer
like video uh photograph
uh gps for mapping
uh so a and
uh voice recording so those are
also um you know tools that um
you would use in traditional knowledge
uh transmission within within this
context
so when we use those
but frame within an
app for a tablet by which we
start gathering information
and then selecting them in what we call
a bioculture database once database
it's when this is stored in the database
then as you've seen in the pictures
the um the
our elders get together in knowledge
circles
and they start analyzing the data
by use of graphics
um this is them tabulated
into into boxes as you see in the u
panna which is kind of a
a chinese abacus the way we use
these boxes you know a matrix
and the ranking numerical ranking is
done
by using grains of mice
it provides you know
the numerical data that we are looking
and which is
them translate it into
into um you know back into the database
and then we mix it uh with the help of
uh you know already existing
programs for uh research
um like i survey or orders
from which we have borrowed the
methodology and we can do
uh the analytical measurements
uh and arrive to some conclusions those
conclusions
go into another meeting
of elders and youth who them
analyze the the resulting information to
take
the best decisions in terms of which of
those
um or how to apply that information
solving problems it could be a
pest or disease in a crop
it could be soil fertility it could be
water management it could be policy
so um the matrix idea that
our ancestors are incas use automatic
stool
that our ancestor incas used to use
you know they um of course they
um allow us to
um to um
create this this type of um
of approach of uh i mean
a process um and then once
it's um the decision is made
then the community assembly sanctions
and becomes part of
a life plan so it's included in
in a long-term plan which
the local authorities have the
obligation to implement
so that's more or less the how we
combine you know our old tools
um more often from
modern tools uh the mechanics of doing
that
and produce results that can be useful
to particular um situations
or problem solving that are more
localized
i don't know if that responds to
question christina
yes thank you very much i mean maybe
i'll just add to clarify
um because i i know about the transect
use and in the in the maze park they've
been doing
transects walking through the landscape
using
um you know smartphones with this app
and the elder
um or community researcher
and the youth and maybe a staff from the
local ngo are scientists
they walk together and there's probably
more
people from the communities and in that
way they can do a transect
looking at the plants with the elders
talking about their uses
and the knowledge being transferred to
the youth and the
the the plant being having a botanical
name and that goes in
as they walk to see each plant they have
a discussion
sharing knowledge and they take a
picture and they put the information in
and
they collect information about um
medicinal and nutritious
wild plants and that's all gone straight
into their community database
um so anyway i just thought um trying to
give it
uh some practical um example of how it's
used
right well we're coming close to the end
um
we we still have a few minutes of
discussion um
i put a question in the agenda um
how can interdisciplinary methods be
used in a decolonizing
participatory action research framework
i don't know if anybody um wants to
comment on that
i guess we've heard about lots of um
interdisciplinary methods ethnobotany
we've heard about um archaea botany um
and we've heard about oral histories
and i i don't know if anyone wants to
reflect or comment on
their usefulness for um
indigenous lead research
could you see that if i may do you allow
me
yes go ahead please um i think that
what you have said is um very important
but it's
part of the whole picture you know
um we are
reducing this discussion to
uh the practice of research in the field
where you have to be respectful you have
to
follow private informed consent
and try to support the local movement
in terms of decolonizing processes
but that decolonizing must also happen
in research
institutions if you see many of the
institutions
out there that do
this type of research you know
they don't have any indigenous academic
or researchers in their
staff all you know
research is done in a way that
is cheap to hire in digital researchers
in the country of origin
you know and do this
and present it as a participatory
i hope the participatory also can
include the salaries
so that this is the same type of
recognition
goes to researchers in digital
researchers
as um at the same you know balancing
with uh those of academics
also the lack of individual researchers
to actually guide you know this
transformative approach
decolonizing approach
in this institutions everywhere
in the world it needs to be complemented
you know with the devolution of
genetic material cultural material that
was misappropriated
that was pillaged you know from
indigenous lands in colonial times
and there's you know long overdue
that seeds
medicinal plants ornamentals
trees go back to the communities of
origin
uh and stop being you know
misused and utilized through patents and
all types of commodifying
methods and you know western
institutions
or what we feel
it's sacred uh and it's exhibit
as a trophies of war in museums and
other institutions
must be the ball doing indigenous
you know quarters so
i think that this discussion
decolonizing research
also takes into account this
other side of the coin
where colonial attitudes
racist white supremacy and
research continues to be very strong
and it's not changing so it's just like
a
a reflection uh on on
your previous comment thank you
uh thank you very much alejandro that's
i fully agree with what you're saying
um i have two questions uh i think
julian would you like to say something
yeah um so actually was a question on
this aspect of decolonizing for
alejandro because i see that the um
there's the use of historical text and
um of european colonial text
and in of the colonization and i i
wonder because we have also a lot for
the caribbean
um but the question is how do you make
the decision of
actually what you know decolonizing that
narrative
from those texts how can how does how
what is the process that the community
makes to actually like oh
this is what we're gonna take from this
i think that's uh you know defined by
the specificity of
what the community considers to be
a priority in terms of solving problems
you know it could be
you know as in our case um
climate change and particularly in
mountain ecosystems
in the andes is one of the you know
existential pets that we have all the
crops are moving very fast
up in the mountain most of our crops are
just
uh you know at the top and uh
we're very sure that we're going to lose
not just the crop but also
you know complete seed seed and food
systems
so in that case like uh everybody agrees
that
whatever effort we make into learning
creating knowledge
uh organizing information to solve those
problems
must be focused on that type of um
on that type of problem-solving
um and then once we have uh
you know the the objective of what we
want to do
then we go into what we have
you know and i think in our case
because you know we have a long history
in terms of having created
a relationship with the environment and
thrive
on it in a very organic manner
that means that we have applied science
and technology
in the past you know for
the benefit of all relations the benefit
no chance of humans
but by the benefit of all so
what type of tools do we use to keep
uh you know focusing on that focusing on
that
uh you know holism focusing on
on that type of balance and
interaction uh that would create
you know um a a new tomorrow
so then we p we we choose the different
tools
be it from the past or or combined
and that's why we we resolve the
question
so i guess in each context it's going to
be different
thank you alejandra i'm afraid we've got
well we're meant to be finishing in two
minutes but if it's okay we could stay
for another five minutes as
people want to ask questions uh you
ching song wants to say
something go ahead you hi
uh yes uh thank you for all the
contributors
uh i handle the presentation about the
biocultural uh
biocultural uh heritage framework really
remind me of
our spiritual leader leader g
shienhu he attended uh uh
the day before yesterday that he
presented about
the uh the community's
bicultural part like a form into
four-part culture physical
which is the eco eco-biodiversity part
and the community part and he described
that
exactly like alexander described it is a
culture spirit as a base as a core and
it is a live and organic process
interacted
within the community and among the
commun
other communities end with outside world
and it's a live process evolution
process
so i think that if we're talking about
the decolonizing research
the first thing we need to do is that
they really need to
understand them learning from them in in
order to
realize that they really need to be
follow the community-based
action research and attach to the ground
working together with them and rather
otherwise
we cannot we cannot understand the whole
it's a whole world it's a whole complex
complexity
a live organical world it's not like a
science it's just a part and a piece
one special actually in one part we
really need to understand
the linkage in the whole systems if we
not with them we we have no idea so
that's what i want to add up
thank you great thank you very much
joshie you wanted to make a comment
please go ahead
yes there is a thread in the discussion
about what can be recovered for example
from colonial archives or
history and material written by
the outsider right now in the cordillera
we had to write our own history
because uh the books that are located
that are used in the schools were all
colonial history right however we had a
very strong
supporter who was a historian and he's
uh he's an american scholar actually and
he wrote
cracks through the parchment curtain
right and what he did was to actually
use all of the historical uh archives
but using historical research
to understand and interpret what was
actually happening
in the on the land at that time right
and that material that he has written
including his other historical writing
became the uh supplemented a lot of
material
that the students and the researchers
the indigenous researchers
used to write our own history of the
cordillera
so there really is a lot of material
that can be
interpreted in our own way that is uh
in the colonial archives for example
when
even in this is not just in the
philippines for example in moluccas when
they needed their maps
to uh record their customary systems
they had to go back to the dutch
libraries
to get that right so um
there is a way of there is another
aspect of the colonization
of those colonial institutions and i
think they are starting to take the
steps
wherein that history is
understood and owned and appropriated
for us to make our own
uh story and i think uh this is one of
the strands that has gone through the
the discussion thank you
great thank you shoji i'm afraid we're
out of time now
it's been great discussion thank you so
much everybody
i'm not going to summarize everything
but just to say um
yeah i i think this issue that alejandro
raised about the repatriation
is um you know really important one and
we've seen how in the potato park
repatriation of of native potatoes
has brought back revived indigenous
knowledge and culture
and um you know created a genetic
reserve that's important for that for
the whole world
and there's a lot of um seeds uh that
that
indigenous communities have lost and
that are sitting in in gene banks
um you know and they could be being used
and used for
for climate adaptation and being
protected in nature
um so that's a really important issue
um i wanted to say thank you so much to
alejandro
and to baguel chilisa and to florence
dagutan for your great presentations
i've learned so much from you
thank you very much and uh thank you to
the presenters this morning
and just to close really a few a few
things that we've learned um in the last
four webinars
we've learned that indigenous food
systems play a critical role in
achieving
sdg2 um and in feeding humanity in a
sustainable way in future in the longer
term
and are resilient in a resilient way not
only to climate change but to covert 19
and also in a compassionate way because
of the solidarity values
and whereas under the current food
system we're seeing growing food
insecurity
and hunger and so indigenous food
systems provide critical lessons for
transitions to more sustainable
and equitable food systems um
we've heard very strongly today that
research must address
indigenous people's priorities and the
many challenges facing
indigenous food systems and this is
urgent because we are losing traditional
knowledge we're losing crops we're
losing culture very fast
and research must also address the
unequal power relations
between researchers and indigenous
peoples and be empowering towards
indigenous peoples
and give them a voice and recognize them
as experts
who have ancestral wisdom that offers
valuable pathways towards
sustainable and equitable development
so finally on terms of the next steps
we're going to circulate the workshop
report
and use the outputs to inform various
policy meetings
um i know this hasn't been a perfect
forum for networking but i hope it's
you will follow up on contacts that
you've made um
i'm really grateful for all of your
inputs all of the indigenous peoples all
of the universities
the fao and iid partners
we need to continue working together
and finally a huge thanks to all the
indigenous experts
and speakers from universities um
and a huge thanks to philip orion from
queue
who we've doing this workshop with and
and the ahrc project and a huge thanks
to the iid support team
to matt wright and alastair who have
provided great technical support
and to beth down at iid
i've really enjoyed it i've learned so
much from you i hope we can continue the
conversation
and we'll probably send a short survey
if you if you wouldn't mind
anyway i'm sorry about the distance and
the um that we can't actually
see each other but um thanks a lot for
all the learning
goodbye